Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about the absolute favorite
thing of computer graphics researchers: destroying
virtual objects in the most creative ways.
This is the only place on Earth where words
like deformable bodies and cutting can be
used in the same sentence and be delighted
about it.
This time around, we are going to cut and
dismember every virtual object that stands
in our way.
And then some more.
In these animations, we have complex 3D geometry,
and the objective is to change these geometries
in a way that remains physically correct even
in the presence of complex cut surfaces.
When such a cut happens, traditional techniques
typically delete and duplicate parts of the
geometry close to the cut.
This is a heavily simplified solution that
leads to inaccurate results.
Other techniques try to rebuild parts of the
geometry that are affected by the cut.
This is what computer graphics researchers
like to call remeshing, and it works quite
well, but it takes ages to perform.
Also, is still has drawbacks, for instance,
quantities like temperature and deformations
also have to be transferred to the new geometry,
which is non-trivial to execute properly.
In this work, a new technique is proposed
that is able to process really complex cuts
without creating new geometry.
No remeshing takes place, but the mass and
stiffness properties of the materials are
retained correctly.
Also, the fact that it minimizes the geometric
processing overhead leads to a not only simpler,
but a more efficient solution.
There is so much visual detail in the results
that I could watch this video ten times and
still find something new in there.
There are also some horrifying, Game of Thrones
kinda experiments in this footage.
Watch out!
Ouch!
The presentation of the results and the part
of the video that compares against a previous
technique is absolutely brilliant.
You have to see it.
The paper is also remarkably well written,
make sure to have a look at that too.
The link is available in the video description.
I am really itching to make some longer videos
where we can go into some of these derivations
and build a strong intuitive understanding
of them.
That sounds like a ton of fun, and if this
could ever become a full time endeavor, I
am more than enthused to start doing more
and work on bonus videos like that.
If you enjoyed this episode, don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe to the
series.
Normally, it's up to YouTube to decide whether
you get a notification or not, so make sure
to click the bell icon as well to never miss
a Two Minute Papers episode.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!